un caos político que se agrava oficiales
de la fiscalía guatemalteca allanaron la
sede del registro de ciudadanos del
tribunal supremo electoral generando más
tensión por su interferencia en el ya
controversial proceso electoral
semilla el Movimiento Político que reúne
voces anti sistema y que está en la mira
de las autoridades prometió seguir en la
contienda política pese a la suspensión
judicial tenemos Claro que la intención
de todo este aparato y montaje ilegal e
inconstitucional es obstaculizar nuestra
participación en esta segunda vuelta
pero el tribunal supremo electoral Ya
abrió la segunda vuelta estamos en la
contienda electoral nosotros seguimos
adelante y no nos vamos a dejar distraer
por estos actos ilegales su oponente
Sandra Torres anunció Una pausa en su
campaña política mientras se aclara la
tormenta que rodea la elección en
relación a todo lo que está sucediendo
hoy hemos marcado
postura en decir que vamos a hacer una
pausa en la campaña política en hacer
campaña y pedir el voto a pesar de que
ya estamos en la segunda vuelta Yo
quiero hacer una pausa porque quiero
jugar limpia quiero queremos
transparencia en este proceso electoral
y hacer una pausa para dar lugar a que
se aclare esta situación
el gobierno nacional se pronunció y
prometió mantener distancia de cualquier
proceso judicial Y respetar la
independencia de poderes pero la
situación inquieta a varios gobiernos
del mundo y organismos de sociedad civil
que temen que esto sea el primer paso
para suprimir la voluntad popular
[Aplausos]